[Music]
my name is sybil richardson
and uh my family is waiting on a ruling
regarding my husband's matter
i was just wondering if you might have
any information on like an update on it
no we don't have anything yeah just with
us on monday
yes ma'am thank you so much okay
[Music]
this is civil person again
all righty thank you so much
my twins will be 18 next month
they have absolutely no idea what it
means to have a father in their house
what fathers even do
[Music]
hello did you get any words from over at
the big house today
nothing yet okay you got a chance to
call today
i have not no okay
[Music]
many of these people have no respect for
other human beings
lives
no matter how sane or how understanding
you try to be it just will make you lose
your
absolute mind
[Music]
success is the best revenge success is
the best revenge
you're going to show them that they
can't treat human life this way
success is the best revenge just hang in
there cause when you get them home they
gonna pay they're gonna pay they gonna
pay
i knew that if it was gonna be it was
gonna be totally up to me
[Music]
hello i'm ann hornaday chief film critic
for washington
welcome to washington post live welcome
special welcome to our spotlight series
we're putting a spotlight on five films
nominated for the
academy awards for best documentary
feature this year
and today i'm speaking with director
garrett bradley
the wife and husband whose story is the
subject of this remarkable
documentary all the time
welcome
great to see you all garrett
the film is a beautiful meditation about
the passage of time
during the 21 years that rob spent in
prison
for a 1997 bank robbery and during those
years his family's life was moving
forward as his life stood still
tell us a little bit about what made you
want to tell this story
um well first of all thank you so much
for having us
it's such a pleasure to be here
um and i'm very curious robert
what your response is because i feel
part of the beauty
is that they were able together
but to answer the question in terms of
part of
that was also looking at incarceration
from the point of view of
family and
immediately was able to build a bond
with fox um
i just i loved her right away and i
loved the whole family
and their story was an important story
and it was a sort of
natural um evolution for us
collectively not just for me as if for
us collectively to continue to think
about
how we could fill this way of talking
about
incarceration from a family's
and fox in the documentary we see
these extraordinary movies that you took
for several years as a young wife and
mother
you're madly you're obviously madly in
love with your husband
um what drove you to start documenting
your life in that way
i checked it to give to your own family
all of us tell us a little bit about
about
what did you want to do that
thank you uh again and gary you it look
absolutely lovely today
i just um um for me it was about being
able to my family was
i was so happy that rob and i had
finally gotten it right that we had
finally built this family we had been
working on for 10 years and
and i just wanted to document it and
then with the choice that we made at our
own hands we lost
what we had worked so hard to get and um
and then by him being removed i want to
make sure that he could
um continue to be a part of our
day-to-day activities that his presence
was important
even though he was um trying to fulfill
an obligation
for breaking the law um and so
my goal was to be able to have this
footage so when he came home he would
see and then as time would pass
and we were still in the system after
over a decade
i felt that it and i was finding out
more that it wasn't just my family but
this was
that our country was notorious for this
that we were locking up more families
than
any other place on the planet earth and
then i knew that it wasn't
just about telling our story but i had
to document
so that all of our stories could be told
the 2.3 million
american families that are having this
experience
and then i was lucky enough to have an
angel sent my way in the form of
garrett bradley i say that i may have
recorded
um the footage our archive but garrett
turned our story
into a masterpiece and that's what time
is it it's a masterpiece
and i understand that the moment that
those
home movies changed hands was a rather
impulsive one
um and i don't know if garrett wants to
take this or fox or both you to describe
that moment when you said here
take these this is for you
gary was so focused on how she was
what she was going to share that she had
forgotten that
you know i had mentioned that we had
footage i
had even forgotten that i hadn't given
it to her yet
and uh and it was nothing but the
universe aligning that she remembered to
ask
and i gave them to her and and i think
the most
remarkable thing about it all is that i
had filmed over 21 years and i had never
once sat down and watched anything that
i had found so to see
what she extracted from that my first
time viewing the film after she had
finished it
with our amazing team at concordia was
um
seeing my family's footage over 21 years
in the flash of
81 minutes and it was heart-wrenching
for even me
and so i can only imagine how it is
impacting our world
what gary bradley has created through
time through our story
garrett do you want to add anything
about what it was like to to get
how many hours were there and
what was involved in watching them and
processing them and deciding
to do it well i think there's um
first of all i think it ended up being
about a hundred hour box
of footage of material and
you know if i'm being honest every
single
part of it was incredible was
and i think the question that myself and
gabe rhodes who cut the film
had to ask was yes we understand that
the structure
the length of the film is going to have
to change we're going to go from
maybe a short to a feature but the
intention
needs to remain the same and so the
intention for me was connected to early
conversations
that i had with fox and rob with the
family which was
why do we want to make this film and i
think as as fox mentioned
you know their story is the story of 2.3
million american families
and and sharing their story was
hopefully going to offer hope to people
and i felt like my job then first of all
the question is well is that intention
in alignment with my intention
and it was so we that's how you create
transparency and trust with people when
you're making documentaries about
what are we doing together why do we
want to do this how how is that
intention going to inform
um how we do it and where the camera is
and
and all of those things and that doesn't
necessarily change in post-production so
when we were looking through the archive
my mind was
it needs to speak to this idea of hope
how does hope exist for the family
in daily ritual in routine and an
intention and i felt like it kind of
boiled down to
probably many many more things than just
three things but three things that i
kind of
narrowed it down to with gabe was this
idea of unity
you know this which with which fox and
robert speak about and the whole family
speak about a lot but
unity what it means to counteract the
systematic separation of black and brown
families since the beginning of our
country since the inception
of the new world unity resists that
you know so staying together over the
course of two decades is no small feat
it's something that some families where
incarceration is not a factor
are unable to achieve which is also
something that we talk about that fox
and robert and the sons talk about
it was obviously love love being the
premise of all things that that
um that they are coming from in the way
that they treat each other and the way
that they treat themselves and the way
that they treat people
who come into their lives who are
blessed to come into their lives
um and it's also being an individual you
know i have to say and it's funny to
speak about you all
you know in third person or whatever it
is but every single member of the family
is an individual you know has their own
thing that they're doing that they're
excelling at that they're thriving at um
and that also is a huge uh it's a huge
feat because it also says the system is
not going to define me i'm not going to
be defined by the system so
those were three uh forms of of
resistance and
and articulations of hope that i saw in
the family
um and i was looking for that in every
single frame and i'd like to think that
the film
um speaks to one of those three things
or all three of those things uh one
frame at a time whether it's the archive
or whether
it is present day
um the the title time is deeply
meaningful it's densely layered
time is um such a fascinating construct
and motif and conceit throughout this
film and one way
um rob that your family marked time
was through your incarceration fox moved
the family to be closer to you
in order to be able to visit as often as
they possibly could i think it was
twice a month um i'd like to set up a
clip that really illustrates this quite
beautifully and then circle back let's
let's watch
all right it is um i think probably
about
2 20 in the morning it is october 20th
and we are on our way uh today is the
21st
on our way
[Music]
18 year old joseph kennedy jr were
charged with the first degree murder of
bobby myers
it's day three of jury selection in the
virginia trial of sniper suspect john
[Music]
muhammed
[Music]
at the beginning of every year every new
year's eve for the past
20 years we have always started the new
year knowing
that this was going to be the year that
my husband was coming home
[Music]
and if you haven't done something in the
courts by thanksgiving
then you know that you're about to end
the year
and you're still going to be
incarcerated
the hope that you've given yourself all
year long are the
truth be told the lie you've given
yourself
all year long you have to accept that
maybe
this just wasn't the year but
next year is the year
rob i one of the things that rings true
through this film
is how much a part of your son's lives
you were able to be
even in that challenging circumstance
could you tell us a little bit about how
you were able to be a father
during those 20 years um
i guess it all started for me uh once i
read a magazine article
once uh in a men's health magazine
and then there was maybe an uh an issue
that was dedicated to father's day
um and it pointed out uh how many hours
per month
uh the average father spends with uh
with this child and
surprisingly enough to me it was um an
average of eight hours it said that the
average father spends about eight hours
per month
every 30 days uh engaged with their
children so with that being said
uh with two days uh to visit in the
course of a month
uh i think at that clipping that you
showed it was october the 20th which was
four days on the other side of the twins
birthday
so fox had come down uh to uh to visit
and it was one of those instances where
i had put him for a special visit so we
would visit all weekend
so it was one of those rare occasions
where our visit was extended
to be a a four-day visit uh with that
being said just on average when you get
to visit save from early in the morning
about seven o'clock or so
and you're able to stay there until
three or four o'clock in the afternoon
depending on what your special visit uh
was approved for it allowed me to be
able to engage my children
uh for far more hours than the average
father was engaging their children
in open society so with that being said
i had to make the best of uh
of the circumstances that i had been
dealt and to
figure out how it was that i was going
to be able to uh
impart uh both knowledge and uh
wisdom uh and allow a uh enough room
for my children to experience life on
their on their terms as well
uh so it was challenging but at the same
time
it was well worth it
i think that's an understatement the
regard our sons have for their father
people think that oh fox you did an
amazing job with those kids
and i say you just don't know when his
the the threat
in our house was wait till your father
calls home
and then wait and if it's really a tough
situation it's
wait till we get to visit you know gary
mentioned the thing about
transparency early on and that was one
of the things that was uh prevalent in
our household is that we were always
transparent about things
uh so it wouldn't it wasn't enough for
me to uh encourage uh for higher
education
if i wasn't gonna seek higher education
myself uh so while i was incarcerated i
continue to uh seek higher education
and achieve at different levels as well
marking
um that you know if you strive you can
uh you can't achieve the other thing
that you strive for
no matter where you are it it shines
right through
and um and both of you to both of you
you've done such a magnificent job i
mean there is such
joy watching these young men come of age
tell me a little fox tell me about their
reaction
i mean there are so many again layers
first of all
their reaction to you filming them so
much i suppose that just became second
nature to them after a fashion but then
what's their reaction been like to
seeing it um
as you said turned into this piece of
cinematic art
yes the art yes you know i think for
them what was funny to me if you noticed
is that they
love the camera and and they would
become mesmerized by
seeing themselves in the camera so i
always just thought it was the cutest
thing so when i see some of the footage
that garrett extracted
um again and i hadn't even watched the
footage the archive footage myself
yet uh i started trying at christmas
and the emotions that came over me
within the first 30 minutes just ripped
my heart out i couldn't take it anymore
so
um i don't even know if i've ever would
have been able to watch the footage had
it not been for geared in this
this piece of art that she's put
together but the kids are i think that
they're amazed and they're humble that
we have been able to use our journey
and that you know it kind of makes the
suffering meaningful
when you can help somebody else with it
and and they're getting messages
in there on their social media where
people are saying to them other children
who have incarcerated parents
other parents who just want the best for
their children um or best for
all of our children in society are
sending encouraging words to them
uh we have a big problem coming up next
month we've got two
college graduations on the same day and
so that's kind of like what life has
been for us lately
oh that's fantastic i this that
that actually um invites me to share
another clip that really gets to these
moments of joy
and also the bitter sweetness that are
that are involved with the joy
um yeah i don't want to set up any
further than that let's let's watch then
come back around
[Applause]
[Music]
time is influenced by our emotions
it's influenced by our actions
[Music]
time is when you look at pictures from
when your babies were small
and
then you look at them and you see that
they have
mustaches and beards and that
the biggest hope that you had was that
before they turned into men
they would have a chance to be with
their father
[Music]
you know garrett we've never seen a
story like this before but i think that
we've seen
stories that touch on some of the
subject matter before and i think some
of those narratives can fall into traps
and and i want to ask you just about
some formal
some of the formal decisions that you
were making while you were putting
together this film in terms of
those traps that you wanted to avoid or
certain values you wanted to advance and
i also would love
to for you briefly to talk about this
magnificent sound design
in terms of both fox's beautiful voice
that lyrical voice and then that lyrical
piano music that
they play off one another just so
exquisitely so
tell us all about it okay yeah well i
think um
i mean the formal choices i mean there's
there's so many different
directions that i could i could answer
that question in many many different
ways
um i mean i think first and foremost
i'm invested in the beauty
and the strength and the brilliance of
people that i
work with um and
i had no interest in trying to get
around that
or to undermine that in a way that i
think
maybe you're speaking to which is that
sometimes i think there's an expectation
um both in documentary filmmaking but
also in scripted films where
to see somebody in their weakness to see
somebody at rock bottom
to see somebody vulnerable
somehow is more true than when we see
them in their strength and when we see
them in their resilience
and i am deeply invested in that
strength and in that resilience and i
think it is an equal truth
to the vulnerability into the things
that we that we
that might occur behind a closed door
and so i think to answer your question
in terms of direction that is something
as a director
that i was really focused on that can
speak not only
um to to the beauty of the family but
also to other incarcerated families so
that they can see
their own beauty as well and they have
evidence in mainstream media
of their own daily resistance and then
also
i think for those who may not be aware
that incarceration is a chronic problem
that it has existed since the beginning
again as i said
of the new world um that they also can
find a way to enter the conversation and
to to be a part of
the awareness of incarceration from a
place that is again deeply human
but that is also rooted in a place of
forgiveness um
and i think ultimately all of the
aesthetic choices the visual choices the
poetry as you say
come from those same qualities they are
mirrors to their reflections of the
qualities
in the family themselves the qualities
of strength and of love
and i think that the music i came across
um
uh the woman that you're hearing she
goes by emma hoy which is sister she's a
she's a nun an ethiopian nun um and the
music is from a recording that was made
in 1963 of all years
that she agreed to do for the purpose of
raising money for an orphanage
and emma hoy was a prisoner of war she
was also a
pianist a prodigy and decided instead of
becoming
famous she would become a nun and
essentially created this own genre of
music which
blends ethiopian and western melodies
together
and it wasn't until i started to
actually learn about her story
that i felt wow wouldn't it be amazing
to bring
these two women together but also this
this story you know the whole family and
and this idea of emma hoy herself being
a sort of uh radical resistor of a
narrative that had been given to her as
well
um so it's sort of an extension i think
of of everything that the film
represents in some ways and and then
there's just the cosmic reality of
um having beautiful voices fox's voice
but also remington as we just saw
uh the poetry of the whole family that
um
that just works real well with the music
you know we got lucky in that way too
well there's luck and then there's
talent and you have both
um and i want to i actually want to
dovetail with with what garrett said
about the the
the kind of large pulling that lens back
on the incarceration problem and fox you
have become an abolitionist a
an activist in this space you in the
film you compare
mass incarceration to slavery and say
you very much are an abolitionist
in that context could you tell us a
little bit more about your activism
in criminal justice reform um it would
be my absolute pleasure i
am a one among robin now among one of
35 other hubs um across this country
that implement a model called
participatory defense founded out of
silicon
valley by um debug and uh our
organization in new orleans
is called pdm nola which stands for
participatory defense
where we teach families on a day-to-day
basis legal awareness as the best form
of defense
most of us just don't know the law i had
a master's degree
when rob and i entered the system but i
didn't know the law and i didn't have an
understanding of the entire process
and and um and so when it comes to our
lives because when you're faced with
charges
your life is literally on the line your
livelihood
you are x out of society when you become
a convicted felon
no housing no loans no no life insurance
in many places
so um it was important
that what we learned we could teach
others and so
when rob came home and we were able to
fight for our own freedom and family
restoration
we now work to help other families who
are trapped in the system
um to or either embarking upon this
system
to experience the least amount of harm
possible
in rectifying these criminal justice
situations
um everybody does not have to go to
prison and prison should not be
privatized it should not be for profit
nobody's harm should be
for profit and so um the work that we do
now
is uh working on clemency um being able
to
um um support our governors and making
the right decision to use the power of
their opinion to reduce
our prison population through the power
of clemency so we have a campaign called
clemency works
as well as a campaign to free
louisiana's longest serving mother
and grandmother her name is gloria dean
williams
and we call it the free mama glow
campaign she's done 51 years
and um is awaiting the governor's
signature in louisiana so
that is a part of the abolition work and
i just suggest that you know
anybody that has a chance to view the
film might get a chance to just
understand whatever their space is
our country needs healing when it comes
to ending slavery
uh even today we are
running out of time but i do want to get
to at least one audience questions so
unfortunately i'm going to have to ask
you to be brief garrett but
john henry from florida asks how long it
took you
to complete this documentary and did you
have a script or a treatment
um going into the project
um i didn't have a script or treatment
i had attention and that intention was
connected to as i mentioned um
conversations that myself
and fox and rob and the family had from
the beginning
which was what do we want to say and
what do we want to share
and that was my guiding light you know
again as i mentioned earlier
how does hope articulate itself
in daily life and i tried to focus on
that every day
um and then i think fox you might
know better than me like the overall
timeline i feel like i know we were
editing for nine months
total he started filming you came and
said fox
we're in it was uh august the 4th i
believe
2016.
and i said we're making history here let
me get this picture
right right right so i mean
you know whatever the math is on that
2016.
speaking of time speaking of time just
being a concept
i am heartbroken to tell you we are out
of time
um it's been wonderful it's
so wonderful to have you all here
garrett fox
rob thank you so much for joining us
you